on the inside of this ring right here of
my engagement ring that he gave me it
says not period going period anywhere
period oh yeah Jennifer Lopez and Ben
Affleck have an everlasting love and Ben
solidified it with a secret message in
her blank okay so lucky it's not often
you get a
second chance at true love
the singer reveals to Apple music's Zane
Lowe the sentimental phrase her hubby
etched on her engagement ring which also
inspired a song on her upcoming album
this is me now one of the songs that I
wrote for the album which is on the
inside of this ring right here of my
engagement ring that he gave me it says
not period going period anywhere period
because that's how he would sign his
emails when we started talking again
like don't worry don't worry I'm not
going anywhere but for Ben sneaking in
sweet messages is nothing new my first
diamond ring he gave me the pink diamond
ring it said sing
and this one he put not period going
period anywhere period
[Music]
Ben and Jen have a long history together
are you guys gonna get used to seeing us
again the pair first started dating in
2002 and became one of the most famous
couples in the world affectionately
known as benefit they got engaged in
2003 but by 2004 they called off their
wedding it was my first kind of
heartbreak fast forward to 2021 and the
two rekindled their Romance you know
it's wild to think about it that way the
lovebirds went Instagram official on
Jen's 52nd birthday which was followed
by a string of public appearances
I've heard you say so many times that
you are a hopeless romantic and you
still believe in love you believe in
marriage you still believe in all of
those absolutely why wouldn't I jump to
April and Ben popped the question again
my love came in Ben came in and he got
down on one knee
said some things that I'll never forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me but it's a
beautiful moment the couple tied the
knot in an intimate ceremony in July at
a private Las Vegas Chapel
[Music]
somebody's getting married
changing area
since second time's a charm seems to be
a running theme they had another wedding
in Georgia yeah it was absolutely
beautiful you know she's got impeccable
taste so the whole wedding looks
fantastic
beautifully appointed Flawless but he's
never been happier I've seen that dude
be happy but the pure joy that was like
radiating from his face it was
absolutely Unforgettable Jen and Ben
know this time around they're not
letting each other go there's no
questions and there is no
kind of like well let's see how this
goes like nope
it's me and you
that's it
all the way
till the end that's it it's gonna be us
[Music]